en direct avec nous romand vigousse
journaliste spécialiste du venezuela
monsieur mais guus bienvenu merci d'être
avec nous alors première question qu'est
ce qui s'est passé racontez-nous
précisément l'effet de cette opération
bonjour merci de l'invitation alors ce
que nous avons pu voir au venezuela donc
depuis maintenant quelques jours est une
étape de plus dans l'escaladé militaire
contre le gouvernement démocratique
constitutionnel légitimement élu du
venezuela
je rappelle que durant l'année 2019
c'est à dire cette année où monsieur
guido s'était autoproclamé au coin d'une
rue président par intérim le venezuela
dû affronter six opérations militaires
au cours de l'année 2019
et puis pour ce qui est de l'année 2020
le 20 mars il ya eu un incendie criminel
donc en fait un sabotage sur les les
machines électorales du venezuela
et puis contre le système électrique le
27 mars il ya eu une opération donc
c'est là la première phase de cette
opération gédéon qui a été déjouée
notamment par la saisie par la police
routière colombienne d'un stock très
important d'armes et c'est la première
phase de cette opération que nous voyons
actuellement donc avec le débarquement
de mercenaires sur les côtes
vénézuéliennes ils sont 43 à avoir été
neutralisé aujourd'hui est bien
évidemment cette opération militaire
répond aux à l'orientation de roanne
gouaille dos puisqu'il ya un contrat
signé avec une entreprise de sécurité
privée north american silver corp erwan
guyot et son entourage
alors où on l enquête en cours que
savons exactement sur les hommes qui ont
débarqué à l'heure actuelle sur les plus
de quarante sommes oui alors ce sont des
pour la plupart des déserteurs de
l'armée vénézuélienne ou de la police
des police vénézuélienne
plusieurs d'entre eux avaient déjà
participé à des opérations militaires au
cours de l'année 2019 comme cette
tentative rocambolesque de coup d'état
manqué du 30 avril dernier où on avait
pu voir monsieur wang wei dos prenant la
tête d'une petite dizaine de militaires
putschistes sur une bretelle d'autoroute
à caracas donc effectivement on a ce
sont ces déserteurs qui sont reconvertis
en mercenaire et puis l'arrestation
comme je le vois sur votre écran de deux
mercenaires de compagnie donc employé
d'une compagnie américaine privée iron
berly et luc bellman dont qui ont qui
sont passés aux aveux donc ces publics
ces personnes sont d'anciens membres des
bérets verts de l'armée des états unis
et ont été contractés par l'entreprise
silver coop
alors selon le président va doro il y
aurait deux heures derrière cette
opération
donald trump en tête et ron wayne law
alors évidemment juan boyau c'est
incontestable puisque il y a eu donc
deux contrats si je puis dire un contrat
général de huit pages une petite dizaine
de pages signée par point de gouaille
ido signé par son conseiller stratégique
et politique juanjo cerrone donne est
signée donc par jordan goudreau le
patron de l'entreprise de mercenaires
silver corp
et puis il y à un appendice qui a été
publiée dans le washington post de 43
pages qui est très intéressant puisqu'il
décrit réellement tout ce qu'il y a dans
le contrat et qui on peut voir
d'ailleurs que ce contrat n'était pas
seulement pour capturer et tuer nicolás
maduro capturer ou tuer mais aussi
inclus et une phase post coup d'état et
c'est un véritable contrat d'occupation
donc évidemment pourquoi noyau il est
impossible de nier c'est encore une
étape 1 puisqu'il ya eu déjà plusieurs
preuves notamment de sa collusion avec
les cartels narcoparamilitaires
colombien et puis n'oublions pas
pourquoi il en avait déclaré que toutes
les options pour renverser nicolás
maduro sont sur la table et
sous la table son conseiller stratégique
en resserrant donne d'ailleurs ne le nie
pas il a bien signé l'appendice du
contrat en ce qui concerne donald trump
bien entendu c'est absolument impossible
que une opération comme celle là aient
pu se jouer sans l'aval des services
nord américain donc nous assistons bien
entendu ici à une percée réalisation une
privatisation de la guerre telle qu'on
peut la voir d'ailleurs sur des fronts
que les états unis ont aussi ouvert dans
d'autres régions du monde
je pense à la libye ou à la syrie par
exemple monsieur mais guus merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et d'avoir été
en direct avec nous